give me a story of somebody that you
never thought it was going to be
happening they were not open-minded but
you were able to get the information how
and why
right so um a lady called hannah
phillips
was
an elderly lady and
she lived with her i believe it was a
daughter and a son-in-law and there was
a an argument in the house
she has it turns out been pushed over
banged her head she's died
this guy
has wrapped her body up in a tarpaulin
uh a big plastic sheet taking her out
into a rural wooded area
before he actually took her there he
went and found a suitable area he dug a
hole
um
deep enough to bury the body
he wrapped up in this um tarpaulin
tied her up put her in a wheelbarrow
wheeled her out to his volvo motorcar
took the body out to this wooded area
and buried her now
there were there were a catalogue of
lies that were told because they
reported her as being missing
and so on and so forth myself and uh a
guy called paul thomas smashing fella uh
we were
detailed to go and arrest and interview
this chat
we go and arrest him because he's saying
nothing i haven't done anything wrong i
haven't done anything wrong
but
and he was very very he wasn't open to
to it at all you know no no no no by the
time
we got him back into the custody suite
and we
he then opened up he realized that what
had gone on um
was wrong
he needed
his conscience started to kick in and
what he actually did was he identified
where the body was buried he took us
there he put
a forensic suit on a white forensic top
to bottom forensic suit on a mask the
whole light is handcuffed to us
and we took him out to where the body
was
the deposition site and the forensic
guys recovered this layered his body and
he was subsequently convicted
uh as was his wife
from that and that's you know that's a
that's a success because the family
would have never got the body back um
it's
not i would say it would not but it's
because we were good communicators that
we actually gave the body out so from
the moment of i don't want to talk to
you guys to the moment of going to
showing you where the body is how many
hours or days is that
well
in this country you can only keep
someone for up to 36 hours 24 hours then
a further 12 hours and then they go into
a um warranty for detention but it
wasn't a long long time it was several
hours before he actually told us he'd
obviously been playing on his mind for
some time was he was he emotional was he
crying was he in a state of like yeah he
was absolutely devastated because
he's his mother-in-law's dead and he's
got a pair of body um
yeah it's it i mean some people will
never crack and some people will
they'll tell you but
as i say the legal system in this
country
i think is a great legal system i think
you know everybody's entitled to defense
all those types of things
so so far one of so far one of the
things that i got from what you're
saying is
is if it's family
you
you negotiate with them based on
conscience
because they're feeling guilty they're
regretful that's one of the ways
yeah you try i mean
sometimes you won't negotiate because i
hated them so much that they're quite
pleased that they've gone um
i mean and but they're all tragic
there's no there are no good outcomes to
any of these because
somebody's died at the end of the day
someone has died and they've died at
somebody else's hand so i mean i've used
the phrase before a murderer is a
murderer as a murderer is the technique
that is used in order to do that now
in the uk
our gun crime is far lower than the us
we haven't got right to bear arms
there's no second amendment is it second
amendment yeah second remember you guys
have a lot of stabbing you guys got a
lot of stabbing
correct yeah so that that is you know
that is the um the weapon of choice at
the moment certainly within the game
culture and in some such as society
the knife and
it could be from a modeling knife
through to a bowie knife to a machete or
whatever but that is the way but the
point i make is
fortunately guns aren't as prevalent
here
so if a cop turns up to a
a job where there is a gun that's been
brandished nine times out of ten
that weapon will be illegally held
nobody will have a semi-automatic rifle
then they'll have a shotgun they'll have
a rifle for killing deer
but the fact is that most people if they
present that
and the arm police turn up they've got a
good chance getting shot because
whereas i watched a video the other day
somebody you know oklahoma
running around with a with a
what he called a pistol he looked like a
rifle and he's doing a second amendment
audit and i'm thinking come on man this
is this is ridiculous we don't have that
situation here so
you know for murders where where
someone's been shot yes we have them
where they have been shot we have
illegally held firearms or we'll have a
shotgun that's been sworn down so it
makes the barrels shorter easier to use
what's the most disturbing case you you
were assigned most disturbing case and
maybe the most disturbing scene you've
ever been a part of
um i think the
uh murder of a lady down in a place
called south end which is down on the
coast um
she'd split she came over from zimbabwe
they were they came over as medical
refugees nice family
her husband decides he's going to have a
relationship with another woman and
the wife isn't very happy with this
so they split up but he can't cope with
the separation so he goes to the local
army navy store um buys himself a
machete and he sits there and lovingly
hones it makes it as sharp as he
possibly can
the lady takes the children to school
and as she walks away from the school he
walks up behind her and
he severs her head
with one blow takes her head off of her
shoulders with the exception of 2.5
centimeters one inch of skin that's
holding her head on
and i think that was quite a that was
quite a disturbing scene when we got to
the mortar because
she'd been collected taken to the
mortuary and when they were preparing
for post-mortem
that was quite a disturbing sight
there are no good post-mortems they're
very interesting um from a from a
biological or a medical perspective
but
none of them are particularly good
and i've been to quite a few
unfortunately what ended up happening to
that fellow from zimbabwe he got locked
up got locked up for life now that's the
difference
here
uh life could be up to
well you can get a full life sentence um
the police officer that's featuring so
heavily in the media at the moment um
who will remain nameless
he's just got a full life sentence and
so he should he killed that lady sarah
everyone and he deserves everything that
he gets um but
life could go from 12 years to
full life censors very few people get
full life sentences really no one goes
to the chair here got it
what do you think about the chair do you
agree with the chair or you think it's
good that you guys don't have the chair
no i think uh under some circumstances
i'll get shut down by some of my
colleagues but under some circumstances
yeah i do
think that is beyond reasonable doubt if
there's dna there's never ever any
chance of it being anybody else and you
know what if you kill a cop
in this country then you face the
consequences that's my view if you've if
you've um if you're a
predatory pedophile and you've killed
children and we can prove that you've
killed them
you're no good to humanity
so if that's true that's brutal i make
no apologies no there's a lot of people
that agree with you you're not alone
there
there's there's probably a few billion
people that agree with you it's not a a
very small percentage of the population
that would agree that wouldn't agree
with you but let me continue on on a
different route so many of these cases
you've been a part of you know a lot of
times in movies you see the good combat
cop one guy comes in and says hey you
want a cigarette here's some cigarette
another guy comes in tell me the truth
hey john get out of here let me talk
about
is that just movie stuff or did you guys
use some of those okay got it i figured
yeah a good good cop bad cop can come in
many different guys because
i could be miserable anyway i don't need
to i don't need to be sitting on a
suspect to be um
miserable or straight faced or whatever
they're not my friend
but my job my job is to get them to talk
to me okay
so
i will
i would work within the law because the
law is very clear around the way that
you obtain confessions in this country
um
and i would deal with them in a
professional way most murder suspects in
this country will have a lawyer present
there are very few that won't have legal
representation um
[Music]
some will tell you if darn it some will
tell you you know they won't i mean you
talked about talk about a disturbing one
there was um
one that really sticks in my mind
and i remember i remember more it was a
now colchester for your american um
listeners is the oldest recorded town in
great britain okay it was there for the
romans put it there and this is a local
town twice it's a it's a military base
it's where a parachute regiment are and
there's roman walls and there's roman
amphitheaters and there's all that is
it's a great place
this chap was convicted of fraud of all
things and for which he got seven years
in prison
he went to prison and whilst he was
there
he
developed a toothache so they sent him
to local hospital in a cab okay
300 pounds 400 later
the guy still hasn't come out from his
treatment so the taxi driver who's
obviously very bright thought oh this is
a bit strange he's not out
so
they're going to try and find him in the
meantime he's gone from one county which
is in kent
to essex on a train
he's gone to his home in colchester
where his wife was
and he stabs her to death in front of
their
baby children and i say baby they're
toddlers they're running around when we
turned up at that scene
there were blood-stained footprints
where the children had been running
through their mother's blood that is
heartbreaking that is absolutely
heartbreaking you know what a cruel
bastard and
those sorts of memories will stay with
me for the rest of my days because
it's it's when your public service kicks
in it's when you're there to work for
the victim you're there to work for the
family you're there to make sure that
justice is brought about and that person
that took that lady's life goes to
prison for a very very long time so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]